außerdem machte sie zum star der novell
war was meinen sie wie so ganz
frankreich sich in sie verliebt hat sie
haben sich in meine rolle verlegt
stattdessen bekamen sie nicht
unser film diese woche ist die burg ein
biopic das vor fast genau einem jahr in
venedig premiere gefeiert hat ist ein
ganz toller film wahnsinnig tolle
schauspielerin kristen stewart spielt
die hauptrolle und ja nicht mal deswegen
ist er sehr viel wert
lucy wird die älteren unter ihnen werden
sich erinnern war der nouvelle vague das
war eine junge amerikanische
schauspielerin die nach europa gegangen
ist als gerade in frankreich die nur wer
wagt die jungen bilden regisseure die
sich nicht mehr mit dem alten studio
system anfreunden konnten losgelegt
haben und die burg war so die entdeckung
die hat in außer atem von godard
mitgespielt hat mit otto preminger die
chance gegeben war da sie das war so dir
die entdeckung der mann der sie entdeckt
hat sozusagen und diese junge
schauspielerin ist dann zurück nach
amerika und hat dort probiert sich in
dem hollywood system irgendwie wieder
zurecht zu finden war sehr politisch
engagiert sehr sehr stark in der
bürgerrechtsbewegung mit dabei als
unterstützerin und es genau deshalb sehr
doll in konflikt mit dem amerikanischen
staat gekommen der film konzentriert
sich auf die jahre 68 bis 71 das ist
eigentlich schon zeitraum wo ihre
karriere so langsam ins stocken geraten
ist wo sie zurück in amerika probiert
irgendwie ins hollywood systeme die
hollywood-studios wieder reinzukommen
ihre familie ist eigentlich in
frankreich sie hatten einen
französischen professor geheiratet und
ein kind dort probiert aber auf dem
anderen kontinent sich irgendwie
etablieren wieder und ist trotzdem auf
der suche und das ist genau der punkt an
dem der film ansetzt wir sehen diese
junge frau im flugzeug mit ihrem agenten
und sie trifft in diesem flugzeug einen
aktivisten der black panther bewegung zu
freundet sich mit ihm an und erhält sich
nach ihm
die beiden sind sich sympathisch und in
dem moment wo das flugzeug in los
angeles aufsetzt und die ganze presse
vor ort ist um die burg den großen star
das große zu fotografieren stellt sie
sich zu den tänzern und schauspieler hat
macht relativ spontan eine einer
solidaritätsbekundung gericht bewegungen
der film nimmt die fbi verfolgung sehr
den fokus wir haben eine junge frau die
eigentlich mitten in ihrer karriere
steht und systematisch von diesem system
von diesem verfolgungen verdächtigungen
schmierkampagne auch spionage die wird
wirklich tanzen werden in ihrer wohnung
angebracht komplett verrückt gemacht die
haben ganz links die weise sehr lange
liegt ich alles auf dem transport oder
nicht das ist genau die regierung der
spannende punkt der das ganze hier zu
einem sehr außergewöhnlichen biopic
macht denn wir sehen sie dabei wie sie
so langsam psychologisch in den abgrund
stürzt sozusagen das heißt sie wird so
langsam dahin getrieben dass sie selber
paranoia stationen oder weiß ist das
jetzt echt bilde ich mir das ein ist
hier was in meinem in meinem haus hören
klicken wenn ich das telefon abnehme
warum steht da immer dieses auto also
wieder ganz klassische paranoia nummer
als zuschauer weiß man dass das fbi
hinter ihr her ist das wären vince
vaughn spielt einen der der serie
krassem hardliner fbi leute die sich
vorgenommen haben an dieser jungen frau
hier eben ein exempel zu statuieren dass
diese black panthers sich sozusagen
nicht einfach durchsetzen können dass
die bürgerrechtsbewegung die die
schwarze bürgerrechtsbewegung sich nicht
einfach in der gesellschaft etablieren
kann sozusagen und das ebenso eine
prominente figur auf jeden fall gestoppt
werden muss dass es die der der
zwiespalt der hier aufgemacht wird
interessant dabei ist vor allen dingen
kristen stewart die unfassbar gute
schafft diese wahnsinnige psychische
belastung zu zeigen die gleichzeitig auf
die schultern gelegt kriegt dass sie
eine sehr starke person
spielen musste er selbst ist die aber
gleichzeitig unfassbar zerbrechlich und
unfassbar fragil ist in tabletten- und
alkoholsucht abdriftet und irgendwie
schaffen muss zwischen diesen beiden
polen zu changieren dass sie unglaublich
gut hinbekommt sie war ja bereits
eigentlich in den ähnlichen in einem
ähnlichen konstellation wie die burg
selbst in ihrer karriere also das heißt
hat in amerika angefangen mit dieser
twilight saga ist dann nach europa und
hat mehrere filme in frankreich gedreht
die die sie eigentlich erst zu der
schauspielerin gemacht haben die sie ist
also sie hat da ein wahnsinniges
repertoire an den tag gelegt hat gezeigt
wie unfassbar gut sie unterschiedliche
rollen spielen kann weit weg von dem
womit sie angefangen hat
und genau das zeigt sie hier eben noch
mal dass man eine schauspielerin die
eine schauspielerin spielt unglaublich
gut besetzen kann und das ist sehr
interessant ist dabei zuzusehen und dass
sie es irgendwie schafft diese schienen
figur so etwas eigenes zu machen dass
man fast vergisst dass das kristen
stewart spielt
sehenswert ist der film vor allen dingen
weil er unfassbar gut ausgestattet ist
also das heißt wir sind hier wirklich in
dieses ganze tolle hochglanz and 68er
anfang 70er zeit ebene drin also das
heißt wir haben tolle ausstattung diese
ganze villa in der christus dort die
meiste zeit laufen muss in die gegend
stammen muss langsam verrückt werden
muss ist unfassbar schön ausgestattet
unfassbar schön fotografiert ganz toller
punkt sind die kostüme von michael wilk
insel
den kennt man bis jetzt aus
beispielsweise mögen hassel wo er die
siebzigerjahre uns beschert hat vor
knapp einem jahrzehnt auch mode kirche
stand sehr
große häuser mit drei gespielt hat
dieser dieser trend und der sehr sehr
akribisch und recherchiert und dann eine
sehr viel ambulante garderobe
zusammengestellt also das ist wirklich
was was man unglaublich gern auf einer
großen leinwand sehen will weil kristen
stewart hier in fast jeder szene was
anderes trägt und man möchte diese
darüber am liebsten mit nach hause
nehmen so schön ist dass und er schafft
auch die die fragilität und dir die
diese unterschiede in der in der psyche
der der figur also sowohl das fragile
als auch diese sehr starke
lebensbejahende sich nicht die schranken
weisen die figur an den kostümen zu
zeigen also das ist optisch sehr sehr
schön sehr sehr spannend schön
fotografiert und wir haben jede menge
andere stars die ebenfalls noch neben
kristen stewart trainieren dürfen also
von vince vaughn mal angefangen
es ist mit dabei die erinnert man sich
vielleicht die hatte nebenrolle in joker
gespielt tolle ausstattung tolle
schauspieler einen film der sich
wirklich lohnt auf der großen leinwand
zu sehen
und auch einer der filme die halt so
lange verschoben worden dass man
wirklich gerne darauf gewartet hat
endlich mal wieder ins kino zu gehen
denn der sommer über war jetzt durch
corona durch die ganze pandemie so
verschoben dass man jetzt darauf wartet
dass endlich die tollen filme auch
wirklich ins kino kommen und dieser hier
hat ein jahr lang gereift um jetzt zu
uns auf der großen leinwand zu kommen
da sollte man ihn auch in ruhe sehen
der film lief das erste mal premiere
große weltkarriere auf dem filmfestival
in venedig vor fast genau einem jahr
der hat jetzt aufgrund von corona
verschiebungen seinen kinostart ein jahr
später und er ist tatsächlich noch mal
viel aktueller geworden also das heißt
als ich den das erste mal gesehen habe
war es ein biopic über eine
schauspielerin
das historisch sehr interessant war
mittlerweile ist black lace matter
passiert wir haben den mord an george
michael hat in amerika wir haben uns
alle gefragt wie das hohe gras
eskalieren konnte und im endeffekt ist
hier eine der antworten getrennten der
blick zurück in die verfolgung in dir in
die kassen gesellschaftlichen spaltungen
die wir schon eigentlich in den end
60ern 70ern immer noch hatten um auf
diese bewegung die dafür mit selber
krassen maßnahmen gekämpft hat um
irgendwie anerkennung zu haben um
gleichwertig in der gesellschaft
etabliert zu sein
das ist ein sehr interessanter aspekt
trierer unfassbar aktuell plötzlich
geworden ist also das heißt das ist
einer der filme die mit ein bisschen
abwarten plötzlich sehr aktuelle
botschaft noch mal mit rüber bringen und
nicht nur ein historischer rückblick
mittlerweile mehr sind